[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONAS JONJEGAN: Hi, I'm Jonas.
HENRY ROWLEY: Hi, I'm Henry.
JONAS JONJEGAN: Quick, Draw is
a game a few of us at Google
made.
You draw, and the computer
uses machine learning
to guess what you're drawing.
AI: I see square, or
suitcase, or canoe.
Oh, I know, it's shoe.
JONAS JONJEGAN:
It's an experiment
that uses some of the
same technology that
helps Google Translate
recognize your handwriting.
HENRY ROWLEY: To understand
handwriting or drawings,
you don't just look at
what the person drew.
You look at how they
actually drew it.
Which strokes did
they make first?
Which direction did
they draw them in?
You train the computer on
millions of characters,
from hundreds of languages.
And over time, it learns
whether you wrote look
or whether you wrote book.
JONAS JONJEGAN:
Training is a big part
of how the computer can guess
your drawings correctly.
As people, it's easy for us to
look at these three drawings
and know they are all cats.
But to a computer,
they're very different.
One is just the head.
One has a full body.
And one is just facial features.
To get the computer
to understand,
you have to show it
a lot of cat doodles.
And then it starts
to see patterns,
like that almost
all doodles of cats
have pointy ears, a
small nose, and whiskers.
Of course it
doesn't always work.
That's because it's only
seen a few thousand doodles.
But the more you play with
it, the more it will learn,
and the better it
will get at guessing.
AI: Oh I know, it's cat.
JONAS JONJEGAN: We put it on
the web for anyone to play with.
We hope it inspires other
people to think about fun ways
to use machine learning.
You can play it at
g.co/aiexperiments.